Hãy ngay sư thành thống của các thống quen đó
Cái sợp khi quen nghe rùi nè là phải đi ra ông phải không nhau
Chúng tôi có buổi sáng mình đi làm của vô mùi ông nhau để nhắc làm
Mày còn đứng nào chứ?
Ê, thì mình thấy ốc đó là một cái thống quen này
Lên như thế, mà khi mình làm mình đúng thế
Đúng là nó có năng lượng thật
Không nên là cái buổi sáng là mình kinh hộ hôn của mình rất chó kênh người được không biết là mình còn đứng này
Cách mình hôn là hôn để mình cưng người ta
Hãy là mình hôn để cả bài cho có
Qua cái đủ hôn mò điên kết đó
Để tảm biết mình còn thương này
Bà cách cách mà mình muốn hôn của ta
Nó cũng nhất trên mình là hãy chung trọng kinh hời trước mà mình
Chương phải mình đẹp nữa mình hôn chỉ vì mình đảm đúng
Đúng không? Thông phiền hả này?
Thì, nó có những cái thống về nhau nhỏ như vậy đó
Nhưng mà nó rất là ngũa
Nếu như chúng ta thật sự nghĩ mình là
Tôi đã biết dùng một cái trị thứ 2, thúng về nó là
Nó cũng có chuyển mình
Đi tôi là ta cái người còn lại có có đi gì vào hồi không biết
Đến như vậy, tôi là một cái người rất là
Là là tế như cái chuyện là nhiều trật thông gở nào vào trong gở nào
Bún sẽ không làm những chuyện nên trước mặt nhau
Để dữ sử dế như
Đặc biệt là những giúp trong lòng với người còn lại
Tôi thấy đó là một cái
Suy hãy
Tôi thấy nó ai
Để bị chúng ta
Thông thì thông
Dì chúng ta không phải kết gì cũng cho nhau thấy
Để nó không còn cái sự lãnh mạnh nữa